so this government failure and this
market failure government failure is far
more prevalent hi I'm Nicolas be with
reason TV and we're at Freedom Fest in
Las Vegas and we're talking with Jean
Epstein economics columnist at baron's
thanks for talking to his chain you have
been working a lot on how the causes of
the Great Recession are primarily coming
from the government sector not from a
failure of capitalism what is your
Witcher which your prime piece of
evidence for them well the prime piece
of evidence and by the way my talk which
I just delivered was called a failure of
crap but ilysm because I don't want to
let off the crony capitalists the people
who supposedly operate in a profit and
loss system but who don't who only know
profits because their losses I'll
protect what's an example of that well
example of that kind of person was
Angelo Mozilo who I gather is mentioned
in a book called I am John Galt and he's
typically I was head of countrywide and
he sold mortgages through much of his
career to the federal government he
originated mortgages sold into the
government he wasn't a mortgage banker
he was just somebody who ran a
government created cash machine now to
get you a question about the evidence
and I've been writing a lot about this
in Barron's so many books on the subject
based on bad evidence because amazingly
when you get down into the weeds the
evidence about the number of toxic
mortgages that the government in the
person of Fannie Mae Freddie Mac the
canoe Community Reinvestment Act hard
independently FHA all of those toxic
mortgages that blew up on us the North
or worse I mean that's it started in the
early 90s that caused a bubble a
ten-year bubble about a bull market
might have lasted a few years lasted
than a decade 12 years 13 years then the
crony capitalist got on the bandwagon
prices could only go up the toxic
mortgages were being issued it seemed
like a good market to get into but the
evidence for that it's hard to come by
because there's been no truth in
labeling does capitalism create cronies
I mean is it's it's not that capitalism
is the problem but it creates the
cronies who then destroyed the system
well there definitely are always
capitalist I mean they used to be
mercantilist they wanted protection too
there are always capitalists who want
cronies in Washington that's the reason
why we have to go back at least to the
Nightwatchman state that that prevents
that makes that much less likely to
happen that's your preferred way forward
which is to reduce the size and scope of
government so that it it can't affect
markets in the way that it has been
realistically how is that going to
happen well I think that I mean people
have to read a book by Gillespie and I
forget who else called Declaration of
Independence that points the way the
only role I play at baron's I have
potentially a million readers at baron's
online and print is is to do my thing as
an economist to keep reminding them that
we don't necessarily have to have a
Federal Reserve we don't have to the
last thing we want the government to do
by the way is is to be in charge of the
money supply I'd rather it be in charge
of the shoe industry even though the
shoes would pinch they would be far less
chaos in the world if the Federal
Reserve were abolished or we at least
have to have to have to limit it so I
the only role I can play is to try to
raise consciousness through Lusa dragon
are people more economically literate
than they used to be I mean this is the
first time we're having arguments about
debt ceilings and about Morgan have
mortgages work I mean or is that the
beginning of change well you know I
wrote a book called econo spending a few
years ago because my more pessimistic
slant was that actually when i started
covering the economy for Berens that was
when an explosion of interest began at
economic
issues but unfortunately that's all so
there was about 10 years later that they
heard that the New York Times hired
their first economist to write a column
in the person of Paul Krugman so in my
book at Cana spinning akola that could
have been devoted to Krugman's gaffes
several chapters were so on so it may
well be that that that the interesting
economics has been so overwhelmed by the
crackpot economics of certain types like
Krugman that's a way now you're rolling
a Nobel Prize winning economist the
crackpot yeah okay well Joseph Stiglitz
by the way also won the Nobel Prize yeah
well I Joseph Stiglitz it the only thing
in his world this is what he won the
Nobel Prize for the one manova prize for
arguing that there is asymmetric
information in the market which leads to
market failure that was his key insult
and the there are lots of things that
are laughable about that insight for
which he won the Nobel Prize but one of
the things that's a little bit most
ridiculous is that he didn't grasp the
fact that when it comes to economic
decision-making institutions always fail
us it's just that government
institutions fail us far more often well
we'll leave it here Jean Epstein
economics columnist forbearance thanks
for talking to us for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie